georges bereta 48 heures qui compteront
dans votre vie et ce de façon définitive
ou quitter l'as saint-etienne oui je
fais le dernier entraînement
certainement avec mes équipiers je pars
à marseille cet après midi si les
contrats se signent le contrat est comme
à l'om ma foi
la page est pratiquement tourné en train
de se tourner elle sera certainement
elle aura fini de tourner ce soir en fin
de soirée si difficile c'est difficile
de quitter son pays son club n'a enfin
plus que bon me retient pas autant que
je parte et que je m'attache aux
nouveaux clubs l'om qui a un public
chaleureux
j'espère se retrouvera les mêmes
conditions de jeu ok que j'avais à
saint-etienne comment ça s'est passé ce
transfert c'était très rapide et
pourtant on a démenti et puis finalement
aussi mais elle c'est simple d'habitude
quand il ya un contact entre le club et
monsieur rochelle ce rocher
quand coupé court il disait et pourquoi
pas roger rocher transféré c'était son
habitude alors là s'il a laissé filtrer
un éventuel transfert c'est que il a été
intéressé par l'argent proposé marseille
vous êtes professionnel donc vous faites
vous ce qu'on appelle une bonne affaire
et pourtant je suis laissé dire que vous
auriez fait de grandes de grands
sacrifices financiers pour rester assez
détresse fait des sacrifices
certainement parce que si on me
proposait de continuer mon contrat que
j'ai actuellement à saint-etienne de le
prolonger
ça vaut aucune raison de quitter
saint-etienne mais le fait que leurs
chaînes ne retient pas et que robin ne
retient pas non plus il n'y a pas de
raison que je continue à rester dans cet
esprit à saint-etienne le dessus suis
déçu mais enfin je pense
la vie continue à marseille a le soleil
a le sourire les gens sont chaleureux à
moi de gagner l'estiment des marseillais
ma foi j'ai fait j'ai fait de bons
matches contre marseille j'espère
geffray je ferai deux bons matches avec
marseille contre saint-etienne un regret
quand même la coupe d'europe
oui la coupe d'europe parce que j'ai
contribué énormément et je m'étais
préparé pour mais enfin je crois que
la venue de ce coach en france n'est pas
étrangère aux bons résultats du club de
saint-etienne et je pense que dans
l'avenir
plusieurs clubs français vont se hisser
au niveau de saint-etienne